à moscou roslan les biefs dirige le
conflit intelligence team un groupe
d'investigation qui surveille les
manoeuvres militaires russes
cette vidéo si par exemple a été tourné
près du village de corée niveau dans la
région de course nous y voyons un train
chargé d'équipements militaires c'est le
deuxième régiment de défense radio
chimiques biologiques
ce train est arrivé à destination a été
décerné hier nous avons ensuite observé
le mouvement de ses troupes sur cette
route jusqu'au village de soudja la
session de juin et là c'est la frontière
selon rous l'asnl et vf loin de retirer
ses troupes de la frontière ukrainienne
la russie les i concentrerait davantage
c'est l'une des trois vidéos publiées
par le ministère russe de la défense il
indique que ce serait le départ des
tanks après les exercices alors que ces
temps que ce dirigeant précisément dans
la direction opposée depuis la gare
ferroviaire vers le contemporain
les divisions que le ministère de la
défense affirme retirer c'est une goutte
dans l'océan même si ce retrait effectif
ça ne change rien à la force déployée de
plus des trous qui on retire soi-disant
et de toute façon base et de manière
permanente à la frontière avec
et ce déploiement militaire à la
frontière seraient selon cet expert sans
précédent dans l'histoire moderne de la
russie
la quantité des troupes massées à la
frontière est suffisante pour une
attaque et une guerre de grande ampleur
et l'on voit que ce ne sont pas
seulement des soldats qui ont été
déployés mais aussi les effectifs de la
garde nationale qui remplirait la
fonction d' armée d'occupation
elle ferait office de police militaire
dans le contexte d'un territoire ennemi
fraîchement occupé
pour ses investigations
roslan les biefs a déjà subi des menaces
et une attaque physique à moscou